hey everyone this is Lucy I'm a
Solutions architect working at AWS and
in this video I'm going to be walking
you through three beginner friendly AWS
Cloud projects now as I've said on the
channel over and over again the best way
to build your hands-on experience with
AWS is by creating a cloud project
certifications are a great starting
point but to really bridge that gap
between your theoretical knowledge and
what's required to land a job in the
cloud it's important for you to think
about how you can use multiple AWS
Services together to build a solution
this solution could be a static website
a mobile application or even a chat bot
that can respond to simple queries the
possibilities are endless but the
problem is how do you get started should
you read through hundreds of pages of
documentation first or should you just
jump straight into it and hope for the
best well to be honest there's no one
correct approach when it comes to
starting a cloud project Some people
prefer to follow a step-by-step tutorial
While others might want the flexibility
to build something without the exact
instructions already provided to them my
personal reference and what I recommend
to beginners is to follow a guided
tutorial for your first Cloud project
and more importantly focus on the
fundamental AWS services like Amazon ec2
RDS Route 53 and so on by working with
these services and connecting them
together you'll end up gaining a much
deeper understanding of how the cloud
works so with all that being said let's
jump straight into project number one
the first project is to deploy a
WordPress application on AWS this is
probably the best beginner-friendly
project to put onto your resume because
it not only uses a lot of AWS core
services but it's also a pretty common
architectural pattern that many AWS
customers adopt you can see here that
the solution involves a VPC with public
and private subnets along with services
like Amazon ec2 RDS EFS and a few other
components so if you'd like to build
this out here are two options I'd
recommend the first option is to use
this three hour video course that walks
through each step of the process the
reason I recommend this is because I
actually bought this course exactly a
year ago and I used it to help me with
the presentation at work where I had to
demonstrate how to deploy a WordPress
website on AWS I found the video demo is
very easy to understand because all I
had to do was follow exactly what was
shown on the screen and listen to the
instructions I've actually reached out
to Aziz the course creator to ask if we
can get a discount for the tech reducing
community and he was able to generate a
promo code for 20 off so if you'd like
to buy the course you can click on the
link in the video description below and
type in Tech with Lucy in the promo code
section when you check out the second
option is to build the project with the
help of three Oedipus tutorials and
documentation I found a free tutorial
that explains how to deploy and host the
WordPress website the only thing to note
is that this one uses AWS elastic
Beanstalk which means that it
automatically handles part of the
deployment for you so if you decide to
go with this tutorial I'd recommend
trying to set up the VPC and sublets
manually without the help of elastic
Beanstalk that way you can learn more
about the underlying networking layer of
the application so regarding notice of
how you decide to build it out the end
result is a WordPress application that's
hosted on Amazon ec2 connected with an
RDS database and is publicly accessible
over the Internet so once you've
completed the project you'll be able to
add this line onto your resume and talk
about the project in your interviews and
if you're enjoying this video so far
please make sure to give it a like And
subscribe to this channel because I'll
be making more videos on how to build
AWS Cloud projects as well as provide
advice on how to land a job in the cloud
industry the second project is to build
a serverless web application on AWS but
before we get into it I'd like to take a
moment to introduce today's video
sponsor skillshare skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring classes for anyone who
loves learning and wants to explore
their creativity and learn new skills if
you have specific skills you're trying
to learn skillshare is a great place to
start from Tech and finance to
productivity graphic design and more you
can find classes that will match your
goals and interests here is a Class by
hashtag learning providing an absolute
beginner's introduction to Amazon web
services if you're at the start of Cloud
Learning Journey I would recommend check
out the class I joined skillshare to
learn more about tech and productivity
and by taking classes like these I hope
to continue building my skills the first
1000 people to use the link in the video
description below will get a free one
month trial of skillshare so thank you
skillshare for sponsoring today's video
so project number two is to create a
serverless web application using a bunch
of AWS services including AWS Lambda
Amazon API Gateway AWS Amplified and so
on a serverless architecture is a way to
build and run applications and services
without having to manage infrastructure
and so this solution is great for
companies who don't want to spend time
provisioning scaling and maintaining
their servers in this tutorial you'll
create a simple web application that
enables users to request unicorn rides
from the wild rides Fleet in this case
wild rides is basically like uber but
instead of cards you have unicorns so
you'll start off with using AWS
Amplified to host your website and then
create a Cognito usable to manage user
accounts after to that you'll build a
serverless backend and develop a restful
API if none of that made any sense to
you don't worry the tutorial explains
everything as you go along the steps you
can see here that they estimate it will
take around two hours to complete and
it's a tutorial that's aimed at
beginners project number three is where
things get interesting in this project
you'll get the chance to explore AWS
services like Amazon connect and Amazon
Lex Amazon connect is a cloud contact
center service and Amazon Lex is used
for building conversational interfaces
for applications using Voice and text
you'll see these two Services commonly
used by companies who want a way to
provide a personalized experience for
their customers so in this Workshop
you'll initially build a very simple
example of a flow for a customer service
chatbot using Amazon Lex and this is for
a fictitious fintech company once you've
built the chatbot you're integrated with
Amazon connect to create a core Center
workflow I've tried out this Workshop
myself and this is probably the one I
had the most fun doing I'll put a link
to the workshop as well well as
everything else we mentioned in the
video description below if you want to
give it a go yourself alright so there
you have it three beginner friendly AWS
Cloud projects to help you build your
technical skills and land a job in the
cloud industry don't forget to give this
video a like if you found it helpful and
I'll see you in the next video bye for
now